hello see zis world and welcome to the
first episode of a new webseries called
true fear in this webseries I'm going to
be stepping outside the world of fiction
to talk about some real-life scary
stories that have happened in the world
and I know that they're true because
they personally happened to me
this episode will detail my late-night
run-in with a creepy urban sleepwalker
or at least that's what I thought was
going on
here's how it went down so it started
when I was on my way home from my
girlfriend at the Times house she was
going to visit family that weekend so I
went up one last time to visit her
before she left so basically I ended up
walking home pretty late at night and
also this is not the best neighborhood
I've heard gunshots
apparently there's a meth issue so I'm
crossing over the last intersection to
get back to my apartment and there's
just this guy standing there at the
corner this guy had dark skin he was
wearing a dress shirt he had a tie on
he had a messenger bag over his shoulder
who's wearing black pants and he was
just a pretty tall and intimidating
figure I'm waiting for the light and I'm
standing perpendicular to where he's
standing the light changes and he
doesn't move I'm getting kind of nervous
because I have to cross over this way
and basically cross in front of him to
get back to my apartment so all this
stuff is going through my head I'm
thinking is this guy gonna mug me is he
mentally ill is he insane it looks like
he's just standing there waiting for me
so I crossed the street as I get closer
to him I feel like he's gonna say
something to me and I try not to make
eye contact but I just started to get
this feeling that he's gonna reach out
and grab me or something as I cross in
front of him I steal a glance and I
noticed that his eyes are just closed so
I'm walking back to my apartment and I'm
thinking what's going on with that guy
that's pretty creepy that he's just
standing there with his eyes closed and
the idea that he was sleepwalking hadn't
really come to me I honestly just
thought he was kind of a weirdo at this
point as I get to my apartment I'm just
thinking more and more about how weird
that whole situation was I want to go
and get some video evidence of it but I
kind of doubt that the guy's still
standing out there after quite a few
minutes so I grabbed my roommate who's
also into mysterious things tell him
about the situation and we go to check
it out sure enough the guy has not moved
whatsoever so we get out there we're
behind him now about 50 feet away and
it's just quiet it's 2:00 in the morning
there's no people out there's no cars
out and we're keeping our voices down
low
we talked about him so that he doesn't
hear us if he is awake as we're debating
whether or not to get closer I snap a
quick photo and video now it's pretty
far away it's not the best evidence and
it's at night so it's a little bit hard
to see but the figure is just really
creepy standing there at the end of the
corner and it's the only evidence that I
have from that night
so finally we decide ok we'll just walk
forward we'll walk past him see what
happens check things out and as we get
closer the guy just drops and he catches
himself with his left leg and he's
almost like in the stretching position
like he's lunging to the left and he
gets to that position we just freeze
we're like ok what's going on here then
he proceeds to stick in that position
for quite a while longer we're not
exactly sure what to do and I know I
probably should have gotten another
picture at this part but I honestly felt
like this guy was going to turn around
at any point so finally we're waiting
around for a little bit he doesn't do
anything and we decide to get closer
again and as we're walking up to him he
stands up looks around seems kind of
confused and then just starts walking
forward across the street and disappears
into the night we don't bother following
him because at this point we figured
that whatever was going on with him he'd
snapped out of it he'd woken up so this
is when we came to the consensus that
maybe he was sleepwalking maybe he was
just walking home from his second job or
something he was really tired got to the
stoplight closed his eyes and fell
asleep standing up for a few minutes or
maybe he was sleeping in his apartment
and started sleepwalking all the way out
to the street and just stopped there
though that doesn't really explain the
attire he was wearing I contacted my old
roommate recently to see if he had any
recollections about the night and he
suggested that it may have been drugs
and looking back on it I think that's
kind of a theory that makes sense
leave your theory in the comments though
but what's really scary to me is to
think about what could have been for
example what if this guy had stopped
walking a few feet forward and just
stopped in the middle of the street or
what if he really was mentally ill and
dangerous and I just happened to walk by
while his eyes were closed or what if he
was sleepwalking and he would have woken
up right while I was going by and
freaked out who knows would have
happened to me so I was really
interested in this and for a few nights
after that I went outside around the
same time to go check and see if he was
there to see if this was like a common
habit that maybe he's sleepwalking at
the same time every night but I never
saw him out there again I did however
see other things which were perhaps more
scary which I'll talk about in the next
episode of true fear so subscribe if you
have not already also special shout out
to my buddy West Dakota for helping me
film this video go check out his channel
he does day
vlogs but like don't just not check it
out actually go check it out right here
get out here
if you liked this video remember to like
this video and I'll see you in the next
one
assuming we both survived